[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to "Coffee with a Googler,"
all the way from rainy
Sydney, Australia.
But it's great to
be here, because I'm
meeting with Fontaine Foxworth.
And Fontaine, you may know,
is famous for her time
with Firebase Analytics
and all the great content
she put together for that.
But now you're here in Australia
working on something else.
Tell us all about it, Fontaine.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Yes, so I not
only moved complete hemisphere,
so moving from California
down here to Sydney,
but also totally changed the
product that I was working on.
I'm now in the Maps and
Geo org, and specifically
focusing on the Places API.
So mapping technology
is totally new to me,
which has been really
fun to understand
how we actually build and
create our world digitally.
And then specifically
working on API development
is also new to me.
I've certainly
consumed a lot of APIs
while building mobile
apps, but building APIs
has been really
interesting and really fun.
So I'm working on Places API.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
having been building
apps that are all about
consuming APIs, now you really
know how to build one
for people to consume.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Yeah,
yeah, I definitely feel
like I've sat on the other
side of the table quite
a bit while consuming APIs.
So I've got a lot
of strong opinions
about what types of things
we should be offering.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Well, Places
API is already in great shape,
so I'm looking forward
to seeing how it evolves.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Good, good.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So tell me.
Places API, I'm
familiar with it,
but for the viewers who aren't,
tell us what is it all about.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH:
Yeah, so first of all,
I'll start with the word place.
Google has this
notion of places,
which is basically
how we semantically
understand the world around us.
So for example,
if you're talking
about going to the
Google Headquarters,
instead of typing
in 1600 Amphitheater
Parkway in California,
you can just
type in Google into Google
Maps, and it will understand
what you actually mean.
So as humans, we actually
understand the world,
not just in addresses, or
latitudes and longitudes,
but actually categorizations,
like cafe, or gym,
or trying to put
these human qualifiers
on top of places in the world.
And so then if you
look at the word API,
that's really how we are
distributing those places
to all of our developers
around the world
so that they can be using
and consuming all that place
data in their apps.
For an example, if you look
at a local rides app or a taxi
sharing app, that
type of thing, instead
of them having to
keep track of all
of the different
places in the world,
they can just use our API, so
that when their user ends up
typing in Sydney Opera
House I want to go there,
their driver actually
knows where to take them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Also,
something like Sydney Opera
House, like a navigation system
requires that, most likely
to be as a latitude
and longitude,
and then you can decode the
place into the lat/long.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH:
Yeah, so a place
is so much more than maybe
just what a user could input.
But it actually filters
into all these different use
cases that our developers
could have, like navigating.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You
know, I didn't actually
know Google's address
until you just told me.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Really?
I feel like
everybody knows that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's 1600--
FONTAINE FOXWORTH:
Amphitheater Parkway.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Amphitheater Parkway, OK.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Yeah,
I feel like-- yeah.
There's a couple addresses
that if you say them,
some people know.
That's, I feel,
like one of them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: But that's
the classic use of a Places API.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
that sometimes you
think in terms of
my house, you don't
think in terms of address.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Exactly.
Home or work, for
example, I just
want to type in my
sister's name whenever
I'm navigating in Google
Maps, instead of actually
typing in her address, because
that's how I think of it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Is
she here in Australia,
or do you have to
drive across the ocean?
FONTAINE FOXWORTH:
She's not, just when
I'm back in California.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
I'd like to see how it would
navigate you over there.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Yeah, maybe
like swim across the Pacific
Ocean, something like that.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now I hear you're
a swimmer, that since
you've come to Australia,
you've done some diving.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: I have.
I've done some scuba diving.
I went up to the Great Barrier
Reef a couple weekends ago
and did a live aboard there.
Did a whole bunch of diving.
It was super fun,
incredible sea life.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So how has the
relocation to Australia been?
FONTAINE FOXWORTH:
It's been really fun.
There's been a
little rain recently,
which is actually kind of
like California of late.
And yeah, so it's
a very lively city.
It's nice that
people speak English
so I can slip in pretty easily--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice, nice.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: --but
a very friendly office
and great to-- you
know, we're building
products about the world.
So it's really nice to be able
to see all different parts
of the world, so you
start to understand
different cultural nuances as
to how people actually address
and approach Maps.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, cool.
How have you adjusted
to being upside down?
FONTAINE FOXWORTH:
Yes, it's pretty weird.
I get headaches a lot from
being upside down all the time.
But I'm getting used to it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
back on Places API.
So you were talking
about an example,
if somebody was building
a ride sharing app,
and you wanted to be picked
up at a specific place
like the Sydney Opera House.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's a great example
of how the places and
the database of places
is available to developers.
But how would somebody get
started with doing that?
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: So we've
got pretty robust documentation
on our developers site, where
you can actually first start
to understand what are
some of the use cases,
how do you actually
use it, and then
what are some of the services
and the different products
that are available.
Are you looking for
mapping software?
place stuff specifically?
What types of metadata about
a place are you interested in?
So a lot of that is
available, including
code snippets and examples,
all on our developers site.
And then we've actually got
some good content at I/O,
so you can look at
some of the stuff that
shows up at I/O this year.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Cool, and we'll
have links to the videos
in the description
below for anybody who
wants to see them.
I'm looking forward
to the sessions.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Yeah, me too.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now in
order to be able to do this,
like to have this great
big database of places,
there must be some way of
identifying individual places
on the planet.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: How do
you go about doing that?
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Exactly.
So we've got something called
a place ID, which is basically
just an identifier for
a place on the planet,
for a location on the planet.
And if you think about it,
the word place, I think,
is really interesting,
because it
can mean a lot of different
things to different people.
So for some people, if
you're sharing a location,
you really just want to share
a latitude and a longitude.
But somebody else who's maybe
doing a real estate website,
they might want an address.
And then a photo tagging app
wants more of a semantic place,
like a university that's nearby.
Or a weather app might
just want a city.
And so you can continue to
think about more developers
might want more and more
robust or sophisticated data.
So the great thing
about the Places API
is it's really flexible in
terms of the types of data
that we can actually
provide to you.
So whether you just need a
latitude and a longitude,
or an address, all the way to
really rich, robust information
about all the
details of a place,
we continue to
serve the developers
and all their different needs.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That one
identifier, the place ID,
can effectively be
like a primary key--
FONTAINE FOXWORTH:
Exactly, that's
a great characterization.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --to all
of these different data sets.
Cool.
So if I want to
build something that
spans latitude and longitude,
or addresses, or places,
and those kind of
things, that if I'm
working in terms
of that identifier,
that's giving me the
key to everything.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH:
That's exactly right.
And the nice thing
about that is, of course
our world is growing
and changing every day.
So if you consider, like, a cafe
over there that might be there.
Maybe in a couple of years it
might not be a cafe anymore.
It might be a gym
or a laundromat.
Well, the great thing about
having Google maintain
the responsibility for
the freshness of the data,
the developer just really
needs to remember and store
the place IDs, and then
rely on us in the API
to actually be returning the
most up to date information.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right, so
the address will stay the same,
and the latitude and
longitude will stay the same.
But what's there.
It's no longer a cafe.
It's a laundromat.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Exactly.
We are responsible for
keeping that up to date.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Which is
a really valuable service
if you're building something
that needs to find laundromats,
for example.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
Or if it's no longer a cafe,
you don't want to direct people
there who are
looking for coffee.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Exactly.
And it helps us really think
in terms of longer horizons.
So thinking about if your
app is going to be around
for many years, you want to make
sure you're serving the most up
to date data.
And relying on Google is
a good way to do that.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now one of the things
was, that you were
talking about then,
being able to pick a place.
you had the scenario of
picking the Sydney Opera House.
But what about detecting
if you're at a place?
How do the APIs work for that?
FONTAINE FOXWORTH:
So It really depends
on what your use case is.
So you can totally ask a user,
here are some nearby places,
which one are you actually at?
But then in other
use cases, you might
want to actually
detect where they are
if you have enough information.
For example, if you
have a ride sharing app,
and you know where they are, and
their latitude and longitude,
you can interpret
where they are.
Now there is a method called
to get current place currently
in our SDKs, which takes into
effect a lot of Google smarts.
So what I mean by
this is we're not just
interpreting the
latitude and longitude
and turning that into
an address necessarily,
but we might actually
try to factor
in a lot of other variables,
like opening hours,
for example.
So an example I like to use
is if there's this two story
building, and on the bottom
floor there's a restaurant,
and on the top
floor there's a gym,
they might have very
different popular times.
So if I see a user who is in
a place at maybe 7:00 or 8:00
AM In the morning,
and I know that people
tend to be at the gym at
7:00 or 8:00 in the morning,
and the restaurant
isn't even open,
I'm going to tell our
developer that that user is
at that place.
Whereas if it's in the evening,
maybe around 7:00 PM at night,
I can infer that
the user is probably
at that cafe or that restaurant.
So we're able to bake
in a lot of our smarts
and remove some of the heavy
lifting from our developers.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Right, and because it's
multiple floors in
the same building,
the latitude and longitude
is going to be the same.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So we just use that.
There's no intelligence.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: The address
is going to be the same,
but by integrating with the
metadata from the Places API,
like popular times, and opening
hours, and that kind of thing,
you can get a lot smarter
about the [INAUDIBLE].
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's really cool.
So if I'm a developer, and
I want to start building,
and I want to start
using this kind of stuff,
what advice would
you give to me?
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: I think
it's important to first start
to articulate what it
is you're trying to do.
So certainly there's
lots of cool stuff
available in our API, but
think about what problem
you're trying to solve and
clearly articulate that.
And then go and match that with
what we have in our services.
So if you really just
care about addresses,
and you don't care as much about
the different semantic places,
then maybe you just
start with some
of the basics like Geocoding.
Alternatively, if
you need really rich,
detailed information, then you
might find some of our services
like the Places Details
Service would meet your needs.
So definitely
articulate clearly what
it is you're looking
to do, and then explore
some of our services and
how they meet those needs.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sounds good.
So I think I'm going to
get started right away.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Cool,
there's a lot there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I've already
built a Places based game,
but there's just so much
that can be done with Google,
and I'm looking forward to it.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: I look
forward to playing with it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, so
thank you so much, Fontaine.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH:
Yeah, thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's
been really, really fun.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Thanks
for making it down here
for this lovely
coffee in the rain.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah, I
get to come to Australia.
FONTAINE FOXWORTH: Not too bad.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I'm not complaining.
And my coffee
hasn't spilled out,
despite the cup
being upside down.
So thanks, everybody.
And thanks again to Fontaine
for being a guest on the show.
If you've got any
questions for Fontaine
or any questions for me,
just please leave them
in the comments below.
And don't forget to hit
that Subscribe button.